how are you and how who takes longer to
get ready in your household yeah I'm
wearing a black tux it's not that deep
you know men get crazy sometimes some of
us do get crazy what can you tell us
about Hamilton and we know that every
day the cast is coming back what else
can you tell it's not even the cast is
coming back it's that we got the cast
before they left so we filmed this I'm
very proud of 2016 us because we had the
foresight to film the show with the
original company before we started
leaving before the principal started
leaving and and so we've got this
snapshot so if you've got that friend
who brags I saw with the original cast
2016 that brag is only valid for another
year and a half before the world sees
that company we're ready I mean I never
got to see the original cast and I know
I would love to so it's so many millions
will well I mean we're just I'm just
really excited that we get to share it
cuz we know how hard did even though
there's five companies it's hard to see
the show and so the fact that we're
still running and we get to release the
movie on top of that I'm really excited
yeah you knew how much I paid to see a
nine year old to see this show any one
deed Reese's Pieces the whole time being
here tonight though how what does it
mean to be included with this amazing
group tonight well listen it's it's
really special for me I was one of those
kids who watched the Oscars every year I
remember when Whoopi Goldberg said I was
the kid who watched if it could happen
to me it could happen to you I remember
taking that to heart when she won for
ghosts and so here we are so it really
feels like a dream come true every time
of all the songs tonight that are
nominated which is your favorite well
listen I've got kids so
and and Bobby and Kristen are close
friends Bobby Lopez and I went to the
same high school an elementary school so
I've known him a long time so I'm always
rooting for him even though he's a dull
II got doesn't ever need another word in
his life I'm always rooting for him and
Kristen is it great to have to be along
for the ride and be there and see
everything and help him build this
Empire and say I'm gonna keep you
grounded my brother how long have you
been married it'll be 10 years this year
yeah 10 years together 15 15 you knew
the broke dude see that's the best part
when you knew the broke dude right she
was still out of my league was she in
high school yes so did you ever even in
high school shiver and talk to each
other did you say hey I was blasting
mark-anthony out of my like my speakers
on my cassette deck and now Mark Anthony
is in are in the heights a movie that
comes out the summer
so really the distance we've traveled
together is crazy I love that that is
the best okay so you got the girl yes I
did forget the jobs I'm the luckiest
person here
[Music]